it's not like tying a shoe I guess maybe
I don't know
Oh like I should tease it a little bit
first
take three strands from the top of the
head kind of stress right oh I don't
understand your hair I'm gonna stand up
yes stand up
I do the three and then one and then you
grab pieces of hair and then you add
them to each of the third three this is
hard like hey I had it good okay hold on
it was like a restart number four sound
really confident ow
all right here we go oh yeah we cook
with bacon did you just give up okay I
think I'm ready for this what are you
talking about there's a clump oh I'm
ready for this I know how to put a hair
tie on the end nope is there even a
there's no ready
there's no braid so it's definitely not
a French braid and I'm seeing now that
there's a part of my hair that was
completely missed
oh my god okay let's start doing this
how do you I'll do this okay
ponytail now what that's pretty good oh
god what this should hit the fan don't
understand here maybe need some
moisturizer I don't he wants home so
let's see if you have a girlfriend at
the end of video sells like split ends
is this going well still are you
supposed to leave the hair tie in the
middle fishtail rate is too easy well I
have three in mine so I'm not sure what
this is I thought this is just gonna be
an easy video if you could come in here
and play with Sophia's hair for a while
I'm exhausted
no please don't let that be it we're
gonna quit while we're ahead with this
guy it feels like a braid you know it
looks pretty similar to what feels like
you ponytails it in Justin to Bobby I'm
like thoroughly defeated no I'm good no
we're doing this Oh cripes they do it
from the side but then it crawls OH
uh-huh I'm worried that you're gonna
break up with me after that oh yeah
that's that feels right kind of one
throw you a bow and arrow cuz you're
looking like Katniss right now you got
rid of it why did you get rid of it I
don't know she would lose the Hunger
Games with this haircut okay I think I'm
just gonna stop there okay junior hair
tie uh if you just keep your head like
that I messed up this hair tie again why
are these things complicated I mean
that's one complete braid sort of no I
applaud you cuz something happened oh no
no no what what happened here all the
way around I'm sure I'm not good job
babe
I'm not allowed was nervous and it's so
time-consuming it was probably one of
the hardest experiences in my life
that's the office you can find a
boyfriend who can French braid your hair
marry that guy
it's just so sad what's happening over
there oh yeah you don't know the half of
it